three two one ignition
what's the milestone for China's Space
Program the shinjo 15 known as the
Divine vessel lifting off from the Gobi
desert for the tiangong space station
and now the three astronauts on board
will take over from the three others on
the station who have been helping finish
the project for the past six months
comrades and arms we have been waiting
for this moment for a long time Heaven's
Palace is waiting for you to come we're
expecting you you the Tian gong is the
crown jewel of beijing's ambitious space
program as it looks to catch up with the
US and Russia the station has a lifespan
of at least a decade with astronauts
expected to conduct over 1 000
scientific experiments and it could
become the only functioning space
station in Earth's orbit with the
International Space Station set to
retire in 2031 with no replacement we've
had parts of the ISS up there for nearly
quarter of a century it's getting old
and so as a brand new structure with new
technologies on board Modern Hardware
this is really going to add to to the
capacity of humanity to conduct that
type of research in this unique
environment
final module successfully docked earlier
this month the shinjo 15's three
astronauts will now spend six months
working and living on the so-called
Heavens Palace
the main purpose of the mission is to
verify the Space Station's capacity to
support crew rotation realize the first
crew rotation in orbit and install and
test equipment and conduct space-based
scientific and technological experiments
China put its first astronauts into
space in 2003. since then it's landed a
Rover on the moon returned to Luna's
samples to Earth and successfully
launched anti-satellite weapons
the television was live broadcasting
young Louis's return in 2003. I had
great respect and admiration for him the
seed was planted in me for the first
time being an astronaut the first thing
is that you can make a greater
contribution to the country and you can
fly higher and further
last year Beijing launched the most
space missions of any country as it
takes one more step towards what
president Xi Jinping says is his eternal
dream for China to become a space Power
Alex beard Al Jazeera